Now that we know what Twinmotion is and who can use it,
now we need to actually install it.
So what do we do first?
Let's go through that.
What do we first?
Now, the first thing we need to do
is we need to make sure
that we have an Epic Games account.
So you have it signed up.
If you haven't done that already,
you can refer back to our intro to Unreal,
which will discuss how to activate
your Epic Games account.
We're gonna go as if you already have it activated,
and we're just gonna make sure
that we download the Epic Games Launcher.
There are a couple of ways
that you can actually install Twinmotion,
but we're gonna use the method of Epic Games Launcher.
So once we have that downloaded,
let's launch the Epic Games Launcher,
and it'll look something like this.
And you're gonna take a look
and you'll see the overall catalog,
but we're more concerned right now
with the Twinmotion aspect.
So if you click into Twinmotion, you should see this.
More than likely at first,
you will see the Please Wait
if you've installed it for the first time.
Once it is available,
you'll have options available to you
as far as which version from a dropdown.
We're gonna be using the 2025.1.1,
and we'll be running that.
Now, once it is available,
we're gonna go ahead and launch it.
So just go ahead and press the launch,
and we will, in our next portion,
we will go over the templates that are available
and start using Twinmotion and getting used to it.
When you first open up Twinmotion,
what you're gonna see is this home screen.
Now, this gives you all the updated news,
anything that's available, the latest of what's happened,
as well as some community sizzle reels.
Down here, you'll see some of your recent scenes
if you have run them.
Now, you will notice this little red, almost broken links.
That's exactly what it is.
That just means that you either moved your project
or deleted it,
and this will give you a nice little alert,
as you can see, missing files.
So we're gonna ignore all this for now,
but right next to it is the templates, rather, below.
If you click on templates, and give it a second,
sometimes it doesn't like to respond.